johnny Knoxville burst onto the showbiz
scene in 2000 as the de-facto host of
MTV's jackass a strange hysterically
funny reality show that became a
surprise smash hit and launched
Knoxville to stardom hi I'm johnny
Knoxville
welcome to jackass he followed it up
with three hit jackass movies and acting
roles in several other films and then
Knoxville pretty much up and vanished
why here's a look at the real reasons we
don't hear from johnny Knoxville anymore
he's not much of an actor Johnny
Knoxville may be a star but that doesn't
make him an actor after the success of
jackass on both the small and big
screens Knoxville landed roles in films
like The Dukes of Hazzard walking tall
and a Dirty Shame and the less said
about the ringer the better Jeff he
doesn't know what's happening to his
body none of them did well at the box
office or with critics his only
live-action acting role in a successful
film came way back in 2002 with men in
black 2 where he played the same kind of
slightly dumb mischief maker that he's
played in just about all of his films
with that kind of box office record an
industry typecasting it's no wonder we
haven't seen much of him at the
multiplex recently I think I'm gonna be
sick you don't want to do that wounded
warrior this won't come as much of a
surprise but Knoxville sustained a
number of injuries over the years
working on jackass on the set of the
original TV show an ankle sprain forced
Knoxville to wear a brace for most of
the first season while in the first
jackass movie he was knocked out cold
twice
Knoxville would later top that in
jackass number two claiming he nearly
died when a rocket blew up on him during
a stunt
one yet no amount of concussions can
compare to Knoxville's worst injury he
broke his own penis and torres urethra
when a 400-pound motorcycle landed on
his groin to this day knoxville must use
a catheter twice a day I got blood
shooting out my BP with so many injuries
plaguing him Knoxville just isn't able
to do as much in general as he used to
which may have led to less time in front
of the cameras overhaul a jackass no
more while the fame brought on by
jackass helped Knoxville branch out into
acting it also posed an immediate
problem how could an ultra famous star
continue to perform pranks on an
unsuspecting public
well the film's addressed this by
sending Knoxville overseas to perform
his stunts filming in Japan Russia and
India and that costs a lot of money time
and resources meaning Knoxville may have
actually become more famous than he can
afford to be hello my name is Johnny
Knoxville i'm about to end this movie
ryan dunn Stefan the jackass franchise
took a major hit in 2011 when
Knoxville's co-star and close friend
Ryan Dunn died in a car accident at age
34 following Dunn's death Knoxville
released a public statement that read
you'll have to excuse me I'm just very
sad because I lost my brother and my
world got about 130 4 percent less funny
I don't know what else to say right now
so I will close with I love you Ryan I
have a lot of emotion swirling but I
want you to know I love you so very much
shortly after Dunn's death Knoxville
spun off from jackass brand with the
2013 comedy bad grandpa which blended
hidden-camera pranks with a scripted
story the film proved to be a financial
success and may have shown Knoxville a
way forward despite losing done and
without jackass the smaller projects
it's not so much that Knoxville has left
the spotlight then the spotlight has
left him Knox fellas continue to work on
smaller projects that simply haven't
gotten as much attention as jackass once
pride like the 2013 arnold
schwarzenegger flopped the last stand
following a semi scripted turn and bad
grandpa Knoxville worked on two
independent projects both slated for
release in 2016
weightless opposite Julianne Nicholson
and above suspicions with Game of
Thrones star Emilia Clarke working on
indie dramas like these could help
Knoxville finally get out of Hollywood
typecast jail
we do have to get out of here not the
tabloid type finally this may come as a
surprise to some fans but Johnny
Knoxville has a happy life as a family
man a father of three he actually
credits and bending fatherhood with
helping him jumpstart his career before
the birth of his oldest daughter Madison
and in need of money to support his
forthcoming family he brainstormed an
idea that would eventually change his
life I saw something on TV where a guy
pepper sprayed himself and I thought
well that's a really good idea be a good
article about your tests different types
of self-defense equipment on myself and
it was just an article but Jeff said you
should we will fill it for you too those
videos proved to be so hilarious that
they are what originally led to the
creation of Jackass that's put food on
the table but is quiet family life and
happy marriage to second wife Naomi
Nelson at kep paparazzi away and help
Knoxville avoid the harsh glare of the
tabloid spotlight he's earned the break
then we're good thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you want to see from johnny
knoxville next